نعم قبل خمس دقائق بالضبط وصلنا الى هذا
المكان في شارع اوزال هذا البناء الذي
تشاهدونه الان هو كان او هذا الركام كان
لبناء مكون من
14 طابقا حسبما اخبرنا به رجال الانقاذ
قبل قليل لدى وصولنا كنا نسال احد رجال
الانقاذ عن عدد الاشخاص الموجودين تحت
الركام قالوا انهم لا يعلمون لكن لكن
يسمعون اصواتا من الداخل لذلك سيحاولون
الوصول الى هؤلاء الاشخاص العالقين ايضا
استفسرنا عن عدد الاشخاص الذين خرجوا
احياء من هذا المبنى قال انهم استطاعوا
خلال منذ يوم امس وحتى اليوم اخراج خمسه
اشخاص لكن قبل ان اكون معكم على الهواء
مباشره سمعنا اصوات تكبير من عمال الانقاذ
والطواقب الموجوده هنا وعلمنا ان شخص اخر
على قيد الحياه استطاعوا تقريبا الوصول
اليه وهو ما يزال على قيد الحياه
والمحاولات تج الان بكثافه وكل العمال
الذين كانوا او الطواقم التي كانت موجوده
هنا في المنطقه سارعت للمشاركه بعمليات
اخراج الركام والكتل الخرسانيه للوصول الى
هذا الشخص الناجي الذي ان شاء الله ربما
ان كنا معكم سنستطيع رصد عمليه اخراجه على
الهواء او اخراجه على الهواء مباشره طبعا
وصلنا اضنه قبل حوالي ساعه من الان او نصف
ساعه من الان لدى وصولنا من مطار اضنه
لاتحدث بشكل عام عما شاهدناه منذ لحظه
وصولنا الى الان
طائرات مساعدات يقطف بها مطار اضنه شهد
طائرات من مصر من الجزائر من الاردن من
الهند رومانيا وايضا من اسبانيا كل طائرات
تحمل مساعدات الى تركيا وايضا شاهدنا
العديد من الطواقم المختصه طواقم الانقاذ
التي وصلت الى اضنه تصل الى هنا الى هذه
الولايه ومن ثم يتم توزيع الكوادر الى
باقي الولايات المنكوبه الولايات التسعه
المنكوبه طبعا هذا اليوم نائب رئيس التركي
فؤاد اوكتاي قال ان مطار اضنه بات مطار
اللوجستيان وبالتالي حركه الوصول الى هذا
المطار من بقيه الولايات اسهل لكن
حتى الان وكما علمنا اثناء وجودنا في
المطار المشكله هي الساعات على الانتظار
التي يقضيها بعض او تقضيها بعض الطواقم
لحين الوصول الى المناطق المنكوبه او
المناطق التي يريدون الوصول اليها بسبب
احيانا اما للظروف الجويه التي هي سيئه
بطبيعه الحال او واما للدمار في بعض الطرق
التي
دمرها الزلزال الطرق بين الولايات التركيه
في الجنوب التركي طبعا
وايضا موضوع
صعوبه في وصول هذه المعدات وهذه المساعدات
فقط اشير زيدان الى اننا سنبقى معك ومع
هذه الصور المباشره لعمليات الانتشار
المستمره لعالقين وتقول بانه في الساعات
الاخيره تم انتشار العالقين على قيد
الحياه وهذا ما يتمناه الكل في الواقع
ولكن زيدان حدثتني عن ان هناك صعوبات في
اصول المساعدات صعوبات تتعلق بالطقس
بالطرقات فهل تصل بطريقه مستمره او هناك
توقف لبعض الوقت وفيما بعد تستكمل العمليه
كيف تتم وما الذي يصل يعني ما نوع
المساعدات التي تصل في هذه الساعات
الاخيره
نعم لا شك ان بالدرجه الاولى هناك شقين
للمساعدات اولا
الاليات او القسم الاول هو بشكل عاجل
تحاول السلطات ايصاله الى المناطق
المنكوبه الاليات والطواقم التي ستشارك في
عمليات التنقيب عفوا او عمليات البحث عن
ناجين تحت الانقاض وازاله الركام لذلك هذا
هو الشق الاول طبعا اضافه للطواقم البشريه
هناك معدات ضروريه معدات حفر
معدات حفر مطلوبه لهذه الطواقم واليات
تستطيع ازاله الكتل الخرسانيه ايضا يجب
ايصال هذه
الاليات الى المناطق المنكومه المنكوبه
عفوا واضافه طبعا الى اطقم الاسعاف
والسيارات الاسعاف التي يجب ان تساعد ان
تخلي الجرحى او المصابين الى المستشفيات
القريبه هذا الشق الاول من المعونات
المطلوبه لطواقم الانقاذ اشقت الاخر وهو
المعونات المطلوبه لسكان المدن العشره او
الولايات العشره الذين يبيتون في اماكن
اللواء المؤقته اولا او حتى في الشوارع او
في اماكن عامه او مثلا في الحدائق المطلوب
لهؤلاء ويجري العمل عليه بسرعه
عدد كبير من الخيام الاف الخيام ايضا
معونات من اغطيه شتى والبسه شتويه وايضا
اطعمه وادويه لكبار السن للاطفال طبعا كل
هذه المعونات تحاول السلطات التركيه
تسيرها بشكل سريع الرئيس التركي اليوم
اليوم تحدث عن اكثر من 54 الف خيمه تم
ارسالها الى الجنوب التركي لكن حتى الان
يبدو ان هناك حاجه اكبر لعدد اكبر سواء
للخيام او حتى للبطانيات او للالبسه
الشتويه كل هذا الموضوع تحاول السلطات
التركيه تامينه خلال وقت قصير طبعا من
النقاط الاخرى التي تريد السلطات التركيه
تامينها لزياده عدد اماكن الايواء لذلك
هناك مخطط حكومي لنقل اعداد كبيره من
السكان الموجودين هنا في الجنوب التركي
الذين بقوا دون ماوى الى فنادق في مناطق
بعيده عن هذه الاماكن الخطر
وحدد الرئيس